enough about me let's talk about your
situation no it's not that I'll be pass
there goes your desire to subscribe to
my channel ok
lesson learned you know what sucks your
monumentous task of having to deal with
the pressure that society puts on us to
look a certain way I wash my hair today
I deal with it too and that's why I'm
really excited about this video I was
approached by Clearasil da da da product
I know you're thinking here comes the
commercial and you know what no I don't
care if you buy this product
sorry Clearasil but here's what I do
care about one a company who makes
products that I buy in my real life
wanted to work with me and to the
messaging that they're trying to put out
into the universe around complexion is
something I feel so connected to so yes
duh Sports clear so got in touch with me
because I'm an awkward human being yes
Clara cell yah having complexion issues
is awkward a hundred percent but the
thing about it is that all of us have
experienced it music's the most
universal language no I think pimples
are but what Clearasil
really wants to get across that I
wholeheartedly believe in is that one
it's awkward but two you are not alone
because we've all experienced it so in
an effort to share awkwardness with each
other I'm going to share my story of
awkwardness around the first time I got
my first real deal zip here we go yes
I'm a very late bloomer got my period
way later than all of my lady friends I
didn't actually like french-kiss anyone
until senior year of high school and
maybe it's because I call it French
jiffy and late you having
it's on my face so my first real deals
it was when I was in ninth grade I
transferred into a French one class and
because I transferred in late there was
only one seat left in the class it was
next to a girl for anonymity sake I
shall call her loud it was a family name
and it took very little time to figure
out why the seat gets too loud hadn't
been taken so I wake up one morning and
my chin decides to do Mount Everest
cosplay I have a boulder of a pimple on
my chin I didn't really wear a lot of
makeup but I think I took my mom's
concealer and tried to cover up the zit
but that's like putting a scarf on top
of an actual mountain and we're not
gonna hide the mountain with that scarf
no matter how much you try David Blaine
and so I'm spending my whole day trying
to be so unseen by everyone which is
very easy because I was very shy and
quiet in high school so I was already
very unseen I know I was getting through
my day until I got to my French Wan
class I got to class and I sat down and
I could just feel loved staring directly
at me and I wasn't making eye contact
because I didn't want to invite in
conversation so I just like stared at my
desk and waited and hoped and prayed
that if I thought hard enough I could
make the bell ring and class would start
and loud couldn't have the conversation
that I could already feel she was having
with me in her head until right at that
moment loud said to me you have a
massive pimple on your chin so you
should pop it you can squat up you
and then the belt finally rang and I'm
pretty sure that I was head to toe hives
just so full of anxiety I was so
embarrassed and in the grand scheme of
things I had nothing to be embarrassed
by because like I said not many people
paid attention to me so there was no
real stakes and me having a pimple
because no one even looked at me
except for loud and you know what no one
had ever told me what to do with a
pimple so I went home and I thanked loud
not out loud in my head by myself for
telling me that I should pop that pimple
because I went home and that's what I
did and I wouldn't have known that
because the internet didn't exist at
that time so I wasn't able to look up
beauty gurus to figure out what
concealer I should use to cover it or
how I should deal with it and so loud
was essentially my first interaction
with the beauty guru oh wow this took a
turn but we all have stories like that
so tell me all about yours and thank you
to this thing for allowing me to tell
you about mine I don't know that's my
laptop not my lap I'm not a robot with
metal legs but also computer are you
okay
isn't this set very candid and not
completely thought out do you want to
say how many options on the floor I have
four what should have sat right here
during this video to make it seem
interesting look at all these things
that was an option those are all options
YouTube is easy